with one giant who would it be that was
the tweet that was posted yesterday by
the new york giants phil sims on the
photo i don't know that phil would be my
choice i think lt would be the guy that
i would want to hear tell stories for a
few hours
as he drank more and more wine but uh
peter all time
nfl
dinner guests
living or dead
anyone we want to pick that's today's
draft inspired by that giant's tweet
here is the the trivia question to
determine the first selection who is the
only player
with nine or more receiving touchdowns
in each of the last two seasons
d i would never get this
[Music]
marvin jones oh
nobody would ever get that marvin
jones's mother wouldn't get that
[Laughter]
marvin jones possibly wouldn't get it uh
i this is easy for me i've done no
research or preparation the begin the
list begins and ends for me with aaron
rodgers final answer come on aaron i'll
cook you a steak the way you like it
we'll have some scotch or tequila or
both let's have a chat let's have a
conversation and uh maybe i'll maybe
i'll eventually write some crap that you
may choose to read so come on aaron
let's go have some dinner look hey mike
mike i just want to tell you aaron
rodgers would rather report to the
packers than have dinner
he'd rather have dinner with brian good
at coast than have dinner with me
hey i'll take vince lombardi getting
back on a serious note
just because all we know about vince
lombardi
who now unfortunately has been gone for
more than 50 years all we know is the
legend
now
obviously i mean i never i never met
vince lombardi most
i i don't know any football writers
alive who
even as a child would have would have
met or are known vince lombardi but
i just would be very very curious to
find out if
the man matched the legend i think he
probably would
peter do you remember this is a trivia
question that goes way back do you
remember going to see
the vince lombardi play
yes
and do you remember who was with you
uh mike florio
and your wife uh and do you remember who
played vince lombardi
dan
uh what's his name tell me mike dan
gloria dan lauria from the one day and
laurie yeah yeah yeah
who would also be this he was really
good too they did a musical version of a
christmas story he was the dad in that
as well all right uh next one for me
bill belichick
i you know i i i like to torture myself
i i you know i'm used to having dinner
with people who don't hate me
i'd like to have dinner with people who
do hate me so i i assume belichick does
just because i think he hates everybody
i'd love to because i've always heard
you get him away from football he's a
great guy he's funny he's awesome he's
talkative he's he's you know he he's
he's he's a great guy to be around well
that'd be one way to find out let's uh
let's uh sit down and have a meal bill
i'd be i'd be uh honored to do it but uh
i know that just like aaron rodgers that
will never happen
you know my next one really would be
george hallas and again i i'm a big fan
of football history
uh i i think george halas was such an
interesting guy because you go back to
the very roots of the game and he played
in the 20s with the decatur staleys and
then the chicago bears and then
obviously coached and owned and i mean
here's a guy who coached gail sayers and
dick butkus and who played against
bronco nagurski
so i i mean you know how how do you not
want to have
the
the whole
encyclopedia to be able to download from
george hallas's
brain yeah i i i can understand that i
mean this guy uh
connected to so many decades of football
as a player a coach and an owner i got
to go uh a modern-day figure
and and this one's very simple this is
just there's one piece of curiosity that
i would want to have satisfied i would
invite patrick holmes over i would find
out which cut of steak he prefers i
would get the most expensive
best marbled
version of it that i could i want to see
how badly he would ruin that with
ketchup i just i would have to witness
the amount of ketchup that he would
drown his pieces of steak in because he
is uh well documented as putting ketchup
on everything including steak he's told
the story he's been
at a restaurant and they like they give
him a hard time because he wants to put
ketchup on a steak it's like hey i
bought the steak i'm putting ketchup on
it
if you were allowed a fourth guess mike
it sounds like you'd want jake from
state farm
because you've got aaron rodgers you got
patrick mahomes and shirley
uh bill belichick will be the 2022 state
farm
uh ad guy uh hey he did subway that's a
it's a new it's a new universe for bill
[Laughter]
all right my last guy
is going to be a guy who might surprise
you a little bit
and
you know because i think
we're all sort of ruled by when we were
growing up the first person when we
watched football who we kind of idolized
and mine would be fran tarkenton
i grew up a kid in connecticut i was a
big giants fan
and fran tarkinton for a while was the
quarterback of the new york giants in
between minnesota viking stints
but he was always this you know sort of
devil may care
run around make things happen guy
far before far my homes before my homes
and then you know later in life off the
field he's become this sort of
new world guy
uh with so many different divergent
interests
i just think how about fran tarkinton
vince lombardi and george hallas at
dinner
that would be sort of interesting
well and we have time for one more round
so i'll add another one to that a guy
who knows fran tarkin and pretty well
let's bring bud grant and let's do it
outdoors in the cold with no coats on
bud grant is the guy who would make it
longer than anyone else in that
environment uh but uh a guy who has
encyclopedic knowledge of all those
years that he was a coach he dates back
to the cfl and played for the lakers i
think did he play for the lakers i think
he played for the lakers played for the
minneapolis lakers yeah yeah so uh yeah
there there would be plenty of great
stories from him as well peter then
they're from my last there we are
walking to the table six below walking
to the table he's still doing outdoors
he's still doing well i saw him a couple
of years ago in minneapolis and he's
doing really well
mike my last one is going to be paul
brown
and
my first year covering a national
football league team was 1984 when paul
brown had moved of course from coaching
the bengals to owning the bengals to
making all the franchise decisions
and that year in training camp
paul brown was there for every practice
in his big straw hat standing on the
sidelines i watched 30 practices with
paul brown my only uh
regret is that i never wrote down every
word that he said
but i would want to have dinner i'd want
to have paul brown there and i would
want to say thank you
uh for helping me
get to know a little bit about football
june 19 there is an event at the high
school that paul brown attended near
canton and then bengals fans will
descend on the hall of fame to try to
rally for more members of the bengals
organization to get in they've got one
so far in anthony munoz so you made me
think of that when you mentioned it and
uh i they have like eight different
bengals players that they're going to
try to push to get into the hall of fame
they're upset that there's only one
bengal all time who was made
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports